[Music]
okay newbies you're up five six ready
arch those backs kitties am i doing this
wrong i feel like velma is searching for
her glasses
so you know how we're nowhere near the
places we thought we'd be in our lives
we spent the last part of our official
youth stuck inside just here watering
house plants
you have too many plants
i saw west today jewels i didn't see you
you were hiding behind a stack of
containers that are made out of clear
plastic are we actually seeing jules
sexually frustrated i feel like i'm in
eighth grade well i can tell you what i
did in eighth grade and it involved
ruining several electric toothbrushes
very graphic
my life is going nowhere nowhere
hiya kittens and here we go again where
are they all going they're all taking
flights to their futures just like you
two have to do but what figured out
where you want to go
dollface today is the start of the new
chapter for us i went to business school
to become an entrepreneur and we're
putting up a bar for women a bar with
rosie on tap somewhere where you can
yell at the tv while watching the
bachelor i just heard the words rose and
bachelor in the same sentence so yes to
whatever that's for
[Music]
i have decided to work hard and see
where it takes me i will mentor you yes
i have perfect skin and i'm wildly
successful but what is my legacy that
sounded pretty good
who was that he was clearly hitting on
you i thought my days of being attracted
to straight men were behind me and yet
here we are
you texted a guy without my input into
it
so what do we think of jules opening
here how did that make you all feel bad
ooh he might not remember my name let me
just no no no no
who thinks sending a gift just now was a
weird move
i need a drink pop that [ __ ]
that's how friends work
even if it's hard you trust each other
and you show up remind me again why you
needed us for this
if i had one what kind of do you think
i'd have circumcised is it like shoes do
you need to walk around the store a
little and make sure it's comfortable
curve or no curve
these are the questions
[Music]
you